It's the next day and we're back in our last video
We took the silicon pokeball molds and melted down candles and filled them up with Wax
[I] tried a couple of different [methods] for melting down the  wax one method was just putting it in a pot and letting it slowly
Melt but I found a much faster way is just to stick it in the microwave for about three or four minutes this whole thing
Would go completely liquid with virtually no effort at all and at that point could just pour it in now
I let these sit overnight and the interesting thing about wax is as it cools
it actually shrinks so I had to come back multiple times throughout the evening and top it up with Wax and
Hopefully, we got a nice solid wax casting now. I say
Let's start with the red one. [I] didn't do a very good job pouring this I spilled all [over] the place
I was hoping that this would just dry off to the point where we could just peel it up and off the counter and it
looks like that's going to be the case now all we need to do is take our little acrylic sleeve here and
Pop that off the mold
I'm just going to push around the edges here to kind of
Crack that wax and then we'll see if we can just peel it away. I'm really curious to know what this looks like
It's really amazing how well that Seals back together?
Okay, there. We have it. There's our wax pokeball
Some areas look absolutely fantastic
Other areas look a little bit popped and bubbled it might be enough to work with though anyway
There's our red cast let's see. How the blue one turned out now with a blue one
I actually poured in a little bit of extra wax on the top
Because I was hoping that as it shrunk it would suck that in but instead
I think
the top
Solidified before the bottom did if you look down here near the bottom of the mold you can see it's really smooth and really clean
But as we get closer to the top where the air bubbles would have got trapped [it] starts to get [very] contaminated with pockets from
The Air Bubbles and you can clearly see how that translates into the casting as well so air bubbles are our number one enemy
when it comes to casting
The front of the ball came out looking really good though
And the top of the ball is super smooth because there weren't any bubbles there that would have been on the bottom of the mold
So all the bubbles who have traveled upward and that came out looking pretty clean pretty nice
I cut two more pieces of five-inch acrylic tubing and glued them to the space here
And then I took a
couple of wooden
Dowels and glued them to the basis of our pokeballs what I was hoping to do with these was make some kind of a mold
Say out of plaster
And then we could melt the wax out which would leave a cavity that we could perhaps turn into aluminum now
I don't expect it's going to be perfect, but I think it will be fun, so let's try that next
[oh]
[my] ball this came off [dang it] no
Once the plaster is hardened
we should be able to take it out and put it in the oven to bake out the wax which will hopefully leave a
Pokeball cavity that we can fill with Molten aluminum, but in the meantime, we still have some of our leftover gummy chicken
So what if we tried melting that down and filling up our molds with that as well? Oh yeah there we go. Good stuff
[melts] down pretty quickly doesn't it?
It's been about an hour. Let's take a look at those plaster molds and see if they're ready to come out
So the wood dolls did actually stay down because the wax balls that floated up. That's a bummer
There we go. [I] sure wouldn't plug. It's your wax ball still in there very nice, okay
We got our plaster of Paris out of the molds now
And they've got these holes here exposing the wax the idea is if [we] stick them in the oven upside down
we should [be] able to melt the wax and collect it down here this should leave a cavity of a pokeball mold inside which we
May be able to fill up with aluminum who knows we're about to find out right?
So just to recap what [happened] today
we took Wax
Pokéballs we solidified them in a mixture of plaster of Paris and sand and then we put those
Castings in the oven to melt the wax and leave a cavity that we can pour mold aluminum into with any luck though that's left
the perfect [Pokeball] cavity in there
I mean
It's perfect as we can get it
The idea is if we can cook out most of the gases from the plaster today, then if we pour Molten aluminum tomorrow
We'll have a better chance at getting a good cast and as for our gummy and chocolate pokeballs
I'm going to leave those in the fridge overnight
And we'll open those up and see how they turned out tomorrow as well
The other benefit [to] heating these things up in the oven is it's going to make these molds warm
So when we pour our aluminum?
Casting it's not going to have to warm it up so will our plaster molds work will our Molten aluminum
Actually form a solid aluminum, pokeball you're gonna have to find out in the [next] video, so in the meantime
Thanks for joining me [for] this experiment. I'll be looking for you in [the] next one talk to you then!